where are you right now Ryan I am at the
phone bank right behind amen corner whoo
all right set to scene for us well i
just got done watching them set the pins
on 11 and 12 and it's like the army
corps of engineers out there there's
like 17 green jacket guys and they have
rulers on the ground and the rolling
balls by it i mean it's it looks like
it's a pretty intricate way of them i'm
placing that pin placement today how
many times have you been to augusta
before was my first oh man okay so when
you walk in soon as you walk through the
gates what's the first thing that you
think feel smell sense well I think that
just the it almost feels like there's a
spiritual thing to what everybody talks
about it but I didn't you know really
understand and then the fact that I
walked in with my my dad and my two
brothers I'm pretty sure my dad had an
opportunity to go because of his
business in the last three years when I
was when I was in prison and he kept
saying no so this is a this is a pretty
pretty neat deal for us three to four us
four of you together doing if I told you
three years ago you your dad and two
brothers would be at Augusta mo jus said
I wouldn't believe Jeff for sure I I it
would have been too far-fetched but it's
amazing when when you start doing you
know start doing the next right thing
how great things happen for me this is
this is special we got the opportunity
to sit at seven on Wednesday and my dad
got to see Gary Player get an ace and
that was that was pretty special so you
went to open up and down the par 3
tournament so you saw that Gary players
hole-in-one yeah we saw Gary players
lingmerth and Zach Johnson all on that
part all on that par threes number seven
where are you going to be today are you
going to be at 11 hole yeah we got uh we
have our chairs it's pretty neat here
for people who don't know you can bring
your chairs and set them up first thing
in the morning when the game
open at eight and you could leave them
there and no one will move them and no
one will sit in them so we have them set
right in front by the by the corner of
13 and 12 the intersection so we can see
everybody putting on 11 hitting their
tee shots on 12 and then hitting their
tee shots on 13 so we have our chairs
they're like my brothers and my dad are
now over watching the group's tee off
one two and three and I'm going to meet
back up with him and follow them until
we get I think they want to follow Rory
for for a few holes for sure I usually
set up at 16 the left left hand portion
of the green I have a friend who and
he's been doing it for 30 years where he
gets in there and sets up two chairs and
you're right nobody bothers them you can
come back two hours later and those
chairs are still there there's nobody
seated in them nobody's moved him or
anything pretty incredible it is the
integrity I think of it and I think
anybody who plays golf you learn a lot
about a person when you play golf with
somebody or around a golf course it's
about calling penalties on yourself so
it's it's important we got out yesterday
in fact all four of us we played around
at a club yesterday morning and we
played a little two men best ball
scrambled between my my middle brother
and I against my dad and my baby brother
it took 20 holes but we were still tied
after 20 holes and my dad just said ok
we're done we're going home we're
talking to Ryan Leaf joining us from
Augusta Dan Patrick show Ryan joined us
at the Super Bowl and the reaction was
pretty incredible I think people
listening to you and just listening to
your story what you've been through and
granted you take full responsibility for
it but you were in prison for a few
years and I I thought johnny manziel
could and he could learn something from
you or at least and you said look I'd
talked to johnny manziel did you did you
hear from johnny manziel reach out to
Johnny Manziel I did and when it comes
to any of this stuff when the person's
ready the person's ready and you know
for me it it simply was my most humble I
had to be humbled to the point
where I woke up on a prison floor now I
hope when I speak or tell my story that
it helps people not get to that point
but it truly has to be somebody's own
rock bottom until they accept it and for
me it it took the you know the very
bottom for me so hopefully you know
hopefully people will will reach out to
help i have and he'll accept it at some
point and because i think he could have
an unbelievably promising career but you
have to realize you've hit rock bottom
he may not know that this is rock bottom
or maybe it's not before he reaches out
yeah true i mean i thought you know the
first time getting arrested in texas and
dealing with all that stuff you know was
bottom for me but it just it simply
isn't and then there's just to something
that comes with that acceptance you know
why did why while in prison when there
were more drugs everywhere than i ever
could find when i was out on the streets
did I choose not to use it would have
been the easiest form of it for me
because I was so in a depressive state
but I didn't I think it's just that that
acceptance and that surrender that
happens eventually either you get it or
you don't and the only thing I can do
now is just you know continue to be a
service and tell my story and then if
those who listen choose to follow that
path I know a young man from Montana
after seeing your show up at the Super
Bowl went to treatment and he just
reached out to my family this week and
wanted to call and say thanks so I'm
from your show that day so that that's
just great news let me go back to what
you just said it was it was easier to
get drugs in prison if you wanted them
than it was when you weren't in prison
yeah I mean it was rapid in there
whatever you wanted pretty much um pills
which was my thing to those were really
prevalent I mean the guards would bring
them in I was always worried that was my
biggest worry that they tossed my cell
one day and plant stuff on me and I get
Doug therefore for longer and longer so
I he always had to kind of told the line
with them and my friends told me you
know if you
first ever want to see the worst people
in the world go to go to a prison at
shift change and that was kind of a
running joke there but you know it is
what it is I just was in a place there
where I just kind of said you know I'm
done and when somebody gets that point
they get to that point and it's usually
a huge transformation for sure could you
watch sports in prison yeah I watched uh
I watch sports all the time I mean I'm
TV at the end of my bed there i watch
some masters two years ago when Jordan
took 2nd and he was kind of my guy going
into it his first one I I Ted told my
parents I'm like yeah this is the guy I
like sure enough he played really well
in finished second so last year I was
back down in California at that time and
really got to see his you know his
performance that was pretty amazing and
again you know he steps out first round
and does something similar again and
everybody's looking up at him I don't
know how odd this is I you know you're
at a payphone you know bank of phones
there I don't know if anybody's
listening to your conversation probably
going what the heck is he talking about
prison and pills and Johnny Manziel you
know flag placements so thank you i
think they uh i think i've got a couple
look I gotta go how are the conditions
down there since you're our masters
correspondent well the conditions today
are beautiful the wind has been picked
up yet the clouds have moved out and
gotten fairly sunny fairly quick and
warmed up so I assume the players that
are teeing off early are going to have a
better chance of hosting some some
better scores this afternoon that when
supposed to pick up around three or four
and I mean it is wrecked havoc with
where the ball is going to go because I
mean you can look at the hole and it
looks like the winds just completely
behind your back and when you get up on
the green it's it's right in your face
so it's it's uh it's tough for sure you
got to work on your whispery golf voice
though if you're going to do it I don't
have the whispery golf boys yeah you
you gotta order that that's okay right
there but it's it's got to be more down
like this and just sit yeah it's not
good for a quarterback to have a
whispery voice but but you're there the
gust a turd adamant Lincoln my plane
partners in la they went whenever a
wayward shot goes I'm uh I'm the guy
that yells for because it resonated the
whole oh you're you're like Andrew Luck
at the line of scrimmage you know when
you're when he yells out the the signals
yeah if it's loud and it's the booming
for sure don't do it now no no no my
brother my brothers I've left my head up
to my middle brother he he tends to
telligence he had a great one on
Wednesday when bernhardt langer came by
he he jumped up and start clapping it
yelled out feel the burn and I mean
everybody pretty broke up laughing
pretty hard at that went around us so
don't yell out Baba Booey or get in the
hole under God know who does that my
brother wants to yell get in the hole
and I said I won't be sitting next to
you if you do this he might not be
seated next to you it's but it might be
the other way around those say excuse me
come here young man you're leaving a
tiger tell your dad i settle oh and sir
thank you for the phone call oh my
pleasure you guys have a enjoy the round
we will Thank You Ryan the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience